الى اوكرانيا حيث اعلن مؤسسوا مجموعه
ايفاجنر العسكريه الروسيه ان مدينه بخموت
باتت مطوقه ولما يعد امام القوات
الاوكرانيه الا الانسحاب من طريق وحيد
بينما قال احد قادتها الميدانيين الى
الجيش الاوكرانيه بدا بتدمير منشات البنيه
التحتيه وخاصه الطرق والجسور لعرقله تقدم
القوات الروسيه وللوقوف على اخر التطورات
المتعلقه
بمعاركامي ومن كرامات عامر لافي ونبدا معك
امينه
نعم الان الحديث يجري عن تطبيق مدينه
بخموت كما قال اليوم مؤسس شركه فاقنار
وان المعارك رغم ذلك ما زالت تدور في بعض
المناطق خاصه في الضاحيه الشماليه الغربيه
من المدينه وايضا في بعض المناطق الجنوبيه
في محاوله لربما من قبل قوات فاجنر لاكمال
طوقها حول المنطقه الشماليه الغربيه لبخمت
وبالتالي قطع اخر طرق الامداد والذي
يمر عبر بلده خرومبا ويربط مدينتي ضخمه
ومدينه المجاوره
موقع ريبار العسكري الروسي اليوم تحدث على
ان قوات فاجنر تتقدم من الضاحيه الشماليه
بعد ان كانت قد سيطرت على بلده ستوبكي
الان تحاول السيطره على احد الاحياء
الشماليه وهو حي الينوفكا وفي المقابل
تواصل تقدمها من الجهتين الشرقيه باتجاه
نهر بخمودكا الذي يفصل المدينه عن على
جزئين وايضا من الناحيه الجنوبيه انطلاقا
من مقبره ماريوبول وحي الطائره باتجاه
الشمال الغربي مؤسس شركه فاجنر اليوم ايضا
كان قد دعى الجانب الاوكراني الى سحب
قواته من المدينه في وقت تتحدث فيه قوات
فاغنر عن ان الجيش الاوكراني دمر عدد من
الجسور والمنشات منشات البنيه التحتيه في
المدينه في محاوله كما قال احد قاده فاجنر
لاعاقه تقدم هذه القوات التي باتت الان
بحكم اذا نظرنا الى خريطه السيطره في هذه
المدينه تسيطر على اجزاء واسعه من الجهه
الشرقيه بعض الاحياء في الجهه الجنوبيه
والمنطقه الشماليه الغربيه لكنها فعليا لا
زالت لم تدخل الى مدينه بخمت من الضحيه
الشماليه الغربيه فلنستمع الى ما قاله
اليوم بريغوجين في هذا الفيديو الذي توجه
من خلاله الى الرئيس الاوكراني فلاديمير
زيلينسكي بطلب سحب القوات الاوكرانيه
المتبقيه داخل مدينه
اتوجه الى الرئيس الاوكراني فلادي المحترم
وحدث فاجنر العسكريه اصبحت تحاصر بخموت
بشكل شبه كامل ولم يبقى لهم سوى طريق واحد
والطوق يشتد حول المدينه اذا كنا في الامس
القريب نقاتل قوات محترفه فاننا اليوم نرى
فقط الاطفال والمسنين انهم يقاتلون لكن
حياتهم في بخموت قصيره يوم او يومان فقط
امنحوهم فرصه مغادره المدينه لانها في
الحقيقه اصبحت مطوقه
ماذا عن اخر التطورات التي رصدتها
نعم وسيله يعني في الوقت الذي يتحدث فيه
الروس عن انسحاب قريب للقوات الاوكرانيه
من مخمود وعن تطويقهم كامل لهذه المدينه
يفاجئ الجميع قائد القوات البريه
اوليكسندر سيرسكي بزياره هذه المدينه قبل
قليل موقع قياده القوات البريه اعلن ان
سيرسكي في بخموت التقى بالقاده هناك وناقش
معهم كيفيه تدعيم الخطوط الاماميه في
مواجهه القوات الروسيه وميليشيات فاجنر
وقال بانه اعترف طبعا بان القوات الروسيه
لا تكاد توقف هجماتها على المدينه في
محاوله للسيطره عليها ويقول بان روسيا
ارسلت يعني صفوه الصفوه ان صح التعبير من
من ميليشيات فاجنر ومن القوات النظاميه في
محاوله للسيطره على هذه المدينه وقال ان
المعارك ليست فقط حول المدينه وانما ايضا
في داخل المدينه هناك معارك وبالتالي واضح
ربما من هذه الزياره
اوكرانيا تريد التاكيد على موقفها وتمسكها
بهذه المدينه والمناسبه وسيله هذه ليست
الزياره الاولى الاسبوع الماضي ايضا قام
بزياره الى المدينه لكن هذه الزياره لا شك
انها اكثر حساسيه الاعتبار ان كل المؤشرات
كانت تدل على اقتراب موعد ربما انتهاء هذه
المعركه وانسحاب القوات الاوكرانيه منها
بالنسبه للمعلومات التي وردتنا من مصادرنا
في مخمود نعم يتحدث عن معارض ضاريه معارك
شرسه وخصوصا على المحور الشمالي قوات
فاجنر ربما هناك صح وصفه هناك حاله من
الاستماته للسيطره والوصول الى قريه
التي يمر منها الطريق الوحيد الذي ما زال
سالكا الى هذه المدينه طريق التفافي لم
يكن اصلا مستخدما في السابق لكن هو اصبح
الطريق الوحيد بعد ان قطعت القوات الروسيه
الطريق الشمالي الواصل بين سلافيانس
ومخمود وبعد ان اصبح الطريق الجنوبي بين
قسطنطنيفكا
ومخموت صعب استخدامه بسبب المعارك القريبه
منه وبالتالي هناك محاوله للسيطره على هذا
الطريق ربما الذي اثار هذا اللقط الكبير
حول قرب سقوط هذه المدينه بيد ميليشيات
فاجنر هي تصريحات التي جاءت على لسان قائد
اللواء 28 ميكانيكي الذي تحدث فيه عن انه
وصلت له
اوامر بالانسحاب ليس كتيبه وانما ليس
كتيبه استطلاع تعمل في مهام الاستطلاع
بطائره بالطائرات المسيره وقال بانه لم
يفهم ما السبب في هذا القرار لكنه ملتزم
بالتنفيذ هذا القرار فلنستمع
اليوم في منتصف الليل تلقت وحدتنا
لاستطلاعيه امرا بالانسحاب الفوري من
بخموت الى مكان جديد للقتال ما اسباب
النقل في لحظه حرجه لمدينه بخموت حيث
قضينا هنا 110 ايام في الخدمه القتاليه
انا رجل عسكري قبل كل شيء ولن اعلق على
اوامر الدفاع عن بخموت وعدت نفسي واياكم
بعدم انخراط في السياسه في هذه الحرب ننفذ
الاوامر ونعمل بغض النظر عن الموقع
نشكر جزيل الشكر عامر لافي وامين درغامي